go it up schoolboy q I'm right here I
beat your report and I'm here to talk
about fixing my Lakers up and I'm saying
fix the franchise game number one don't
get rid of rounds in here that's what I
would do why because I feel like with
another star player and he loves to
facilitate the ball he doesn't seem like
he's really interested in scoring a lot
he plays great defense he pushes the
ball up fast and I think that's what we
need to speed to pace up a little bit
more we got to get ad there's no hope
we're done the Brian you want I love you
you you the king but it's no way you're
gonna win it without ad our another
superstar their ad is somebody that
really really wants it you can see when
he has the ball in his hand we need some
more people like that on the team is
LeBron the best player at the courts but
he just needs some help man
cause my lover man you know he's a
little beast and I wish we could keep
Kuzma to know it's like his heart why I
mean look at the Angelo Russell I mean
some people are way better when they
leave some people need to potty leave
and go spread their wings a little bit
you know I'm saying that's my my thing
you know the could give us random he had
a great great season this year - it was
like time she got a gift somebody in
player should probably be the pressed in
the trailer - Father's Day you know some
of them do whatever number three he
raised that Magic Johnson was even there
follow the friends let's just forget
magic dipped on us and you realize he
was way too rich for the problems here
I'm cool I've been talking to people
walking here we've been talking about
next year and I'm sitting there saying
I'm not gonna be here I didn't watch
Kobe we're five and a bang
I really want to try to build to one I
feel you managed to get up out of it but
for the franchise the team
you got to wipe that out man you got to
get rid of it and move on to the next so
number four something about that culture
man we got a oh no I wanted to get a
coach but I also wanted to get another
coach that was trash to life that was
like trash that liked playing I don't
like when like a good basketball players
coaching a team but she was always good
you don't really know why something's
not clicking or like I met your magic
Kobe being a coach like brought you
weights who did they try to coach
somebody like especially somebody on a
bench like but do you know anything
about the [ __ ]
oh no but you know how it might be all
right over my behind of Mark Jackson
just might be all right though
now Jax wasn't trying wasn't a trash
player no but he was a good college
all right aside me I go crazy I go crazy
everything I love Jesus
URI our enemy I'm gonna bring them out
loud I got this rapper to be like not
even six feet but the legs bang brothers
this is fixed the franchise
[Music]